und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend es ist arg 5 die kriegsbilder aus
dem heiligen land es begann mit
hunderten raketen aus gaza auf bewohnte
gebiete israels inzwischen sind dass
tausende gewesen
die gegenschläge der israelischen abzug
von hoher präzision und überwältigender
wucht der radikalislamischen hamas sind
die arsenale noch nicht ausgegangen und
israel sieht sich noch nicht am ziel es
geht offenbar darum die strukturen und
schlagkraft der hamas so weit zu
zerstören
das für viele jahre von dort keine
gefahr mehr droht wie seit dem letzten
gazakrieg vor sieben jahren ein fass
logisches ziel das aber israels
vielfältige gesellschaft auf eine
zerreißprobe stellt michael bewerunge
berichtet dass es wenigstens dazu heute
auch ein ermutigendes zeichen kam
es ist ein lichtblick im meer von gewalt
in dem israel und die palästinensischen
gebiete zu versinken drohen eine
demonstration für den frieden die selbst
friedlich bleibt und das sind ja vor
allem arabische israelis leben und das
zuletzt von heftigen gewaltausbrüchen
zwischen arabischen und jüdischen
gewalttätern geprägt war
wir sind nicht bereit den angriff auf
unsere kinder und unsere häuser zu
akzeptieren die sind hier um gemeinsam
laut zu sagen nein zu gewalt
es geht um einen feigen anschlag zwei
vermummte werfen molotow-cocktails in
die wohnung einer arabischen familie in
jaffa zwei schlafende kinder erleiden
schwere verbrennungen noch ist nicht
klar ob jüdische extremisten arabische
familien treffen wollten oder arabische
angreifer nur aus versehen die eigenen
leute angriffen
doch am ende ist das egal meinen auch
die juden die hier wohnen
ich lebe auch hier in jaffa und deswegen
bin ich hier mein kind und das kind
meines nachbarn sind gleich das ist die
zeit zusammenzustehen gegen die gewalt
in vielen anderen israelischen städten
kam es dagegen wieder zu krawallen bei
cesar erbauten arabische demonstranten
strassensperren und lieferten sich
kämpfe mit der polizei gewalt auch im
westjordanland straßenkämpfe zwischen
palästinensern und israelischen soldaten
wie hier nach ramallah die palästinenser
begehen heute den nakba-tag der an
flucht und vertreibung nach der gründung
israels 1948 erinnert
zur gleichen zeit setzt die hamas den
wahllosen beschuss der israelischen
zivilbevölkerung fort heute mit mehreren
angriffen auch tel aviv und die
angrenzenden orte eine rakete steckt in
ramat gan ein und tötet einen mann
ich habe zwei jahre in der armee gedient
und weiß ii raketen sich anhören
ich hatte große angst aber gott stand
uns bei es war furchtbar furchtbar
auch die israelische luftwaffe setzte
ihre angriffe fort mit vorankündigung
wurde dieses gebäude zerstört die hamas
soll dort militärische einrichtungen
betrieben haben
aber auch büros internationaler medien
waren dort wie das der amerikanischen
presse agentur ap us-präsident beiden
soll daraufhin persönlich bei
ministerpräsident netanjahu interveniert
haben später sprach beiden auch mit
palästinenserpräsident abbas über ein
ende der kampfhandlungen
doch noch zeichnet sich kein
waffenstillstand ab lediglich eine
bodenoffensive scheint vom tisch zu sein
aus israelischer sicht ist die rechnung
mit hamas noch nicht beglichen
wenn jede netanjahu hat gerade in israel
in einer fernsehansprache erklärt die
militäroperationen sei noch nicht vorbei
und werden noch so lange dauern wie
nötig kein datum keine details israels
sicherheit ist für deutschland nicht
irgendein element der aussenpolitik sie
sei teil der deutschen staatsräson hat
kanzlerin merkel vor vielen jahren in
einer feierlichen rede vor der knesset
in jerusalem erklärt mehr gewicht und
ernst kann man einer solchen zielsetzung
nicht geben was damit nicht gemeint
gewesen sein kann war eine einschränkung
von grund und menschenrechten in
deutschland jeder hier hat weiterhin das
recht seine meinung frei und öffentlich
kund zu tun oder auch herauszuschreien
auch in demonstrationen
solange die friedlich bleiben regeln
folgen und weder hass noch hetze
verbreiten so wie heute wenigstens
überwiegend susanna santina berichtet
israel existiert nicht steht auf diesem
plakat alles ist palästina
in berlin versammelten sich mehr als
3.500 pro-palästinensische demonstranten
die stimmung aufgeheizt
am abend kam es zum teil zu schweren
ausschreitungen
aus den reihen der demonstranten flogen
flaschen und feuerwerkskörper gegen die
sicherheitskräfte
es gab verletzte und festnahmen
friedlich blieb es in frankfurt am main
der zorn der demonstranten beschränkte
sich auf worte vor allem zur
israelischen regierung und ihrer
siedlungspolitik
wir schwören dass wir die
al-aksa-moschee schützen rufen sie
wir haben nicht gegen juden nur dagegen
ein antrag überhaupt nichts das geht nur
und kriege dass die sofort aufhört
israelis die beschützen uns nicht nein
sehen sie sich in what was passiert
sehen sie sich in japan was passiert die
demonstration in frankfurt war zunächst
verboten worden
die veranstalter hatten geklagt und vom
verwaltungsgericht recht bekommen
dabei hätten sie zur vernichtung israels
aufgerufen sagt die jüdische gemeinde
und kann die entscheidung nicht
verstehen
insgesamt seien schockiert über den
unverhohlenen antisemitismus auf den
demos in den letzten tagen
wir fordern von der politik und von der
polizei hartes und entschlossenes
durchgreifen wir brauchen in diesen für
uns schweren zeiten nicht nur die
solidarität der politik sondern die
solidarität der gesamten gesellschaft
antisemitismus erleben die jungen
spieler von makkabi frankfurt sehr oft
auch wenn hier jeder mitspielen kann
egal welcher nationalität oder religion
es ist ein jüdischer fußballverein
präsident meyer sagt dass die jungs
deswegen immer wieder beschimpft und
sogar angegriffen werden
scheuch hat man vergessen zu vergasen
bis hin zu ziehen juden trikot aus und
dann auch handgreiflichkeiten direkt
nach dem spiel oder bis hin zu
messerattacken auch das habe schon
gespürt
viele eltern hier machen sich sorgen um
ihre kinder die antisemitischen vorfälle
auf den demos in den vergangenen tagen
sind wir sie nicht überraschend ist ein
konglomerat von leuten die einfach dass
jetzt die möglichkeit finden ihren hass
auf die straße zu bringen das ist schon
gefährlich
also ich denke dass das der
antisemitismus nach wie vor vorhanden
ist und dass er sich verändert über die
jahre aber dass es immer wieder thema
ist natürlich macht ihnen das sorgen
der wachsende antisemitismus wurde heute
auch bei der demonstration in berlin
angeprangert ein pro israelisches
bündnis forderte außerdem das ende des
raketenbeschusses aus dem gazastreifen
der kriege im nahen osten bewegt auch
heute wieder viele menschen in
deutschland
nachrichten von gundula die zahl der
korona neuinfektionen in deutschland
geht weiter zurück in immer mehr
landkreise
sinken die instanzen unter den als
kritisch definierten wert von 100
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen warnte
aber erneut und eindringlich vor zu
schnellen lockerungen das robert koch
institut registrierte fast 7900 fälle
binnen 24 stunden das sind fast 7800
weniger als vor einer woche
177 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus die bundesweite sieben tage
ins ident ist weiter zurückgegangen auf
87,3 seit beginn der korona krisen sind
zwischen 350 und 800 stunden
präsenzunterricht für jeden schüler
ausgefallen
das schätzt der präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes meidinger
der bild zeitung sagte er das sei im
schnitt ein halbes schuljahr zum
ausgleich forderte er für das nächste
schuljahr verpflichtende zusatzangebote
für schüler am nachmittag am wochenende
und in den ferien und ohne
lehramtsstudierende und pensionierte
lehrer werde es nicht gehen
am zweiten tag des digitalen
fdp-parteitages stand das programm für
die bundestagswahl im mittelpunkt die
liberalen gehen auch in diesen wahlkampf
mit einem klaren nein zu
steuererhöhungen
der im amt bestätigte generalsekretär
wissing lehnte außerdem eine weitere
verschuldung zur bewältigung der
pandemie folgen ab ebenso staatliche
vorgaben etwa bei der klimapolitik
optionen für mögliche
regierungsbeteiligungen hält sich die
fdp offen
die afg in niedersachsen hat ihren
außerordentlichen landesparteitag in
braunschweig wegen überfüllung abbrechen
müssen
da mehr stimmberechtigte
parteimitglieder erschienen waren als
unter corona auflagen in den saal
gedurft hätten musste der parteitag
vorzeitig beendet werden
chinas erster mars mission war
erfolgreich
ein raumschiff modul konnte sicher auf
dem roten planeten landen
es war im vergangenen juli von der erde
aufgebrochen an bord der rover suhre
er soll daten über die geologische
struktur und das klima sammeln in den
letzten jahren glückten die meist
marsmissionen den usa deren rover
providence ist seit februar auf dem mars
unterwegs
in diesem langen wochenende kommen die
christlichen kirchen in deutschland zu
einem gemeinsamen einem ökumenischen
kirchentag zusammen
es ist ein ereignis das es nur in vielen
jahren zeitabstand gibt also nichts was
man leichten herzens verschieben würde
auch wenn das treffen diesmal ein
weitgehend virtuelles sein muss der
zeitpunkt ist trotzdem genau richtig die
kirchen stehen gerade alle vor gleichen
problemen vor verlorener glaubwürdigkeit
wenn es darum geht wie sie in ihren
reihen missbrauch von macht gegenüber
schutzbefohlenen aufarbeiten
massenhaften auszug der gläubigen aus
der amtskirche wachsende gräben zwischen
religionen weltweit ein berg von
problemen für ein ziemlich reduziertes
treffen
lincoln klinge verfolgt das im netz und
im realen den die evangelische
kirchentagspräsident in bettina limberg
empfängt am abend die kommunion im
katholischen dom in frankfurt gemeinsam
mit dem limburger bischof bätzing ein
deutliches zeichen dass vom ökumenischen
kirchentag ausgeht die einladung zur
gegenseitigen mahlfeier damit riskiert
besonders die katholische kirche fiel
vor allem einen konflikt mit ruhm
im kombi geht es ja nur darum dass wir
sagen wer in gewissen sich entscheidet
dann zur heiligen kommunion hinzuzufügen
der wird nicht abgewiesen der ist
willkommen und das entspricht auch dem
was katholische praxis schon längere
zeit ist aber es ist in dieser bewussten
art und weise schon ein besonderes
aufmerken
den gesamten tag wurde heute zum
beispiel aus diesem studio der
ökumenische kirchentag gestreamt in
diskussionen und videos ging es auch um
politische themen wie klima soziale
gerechtigkeit und die korona pandemie
kirche will sich einmischen und zeigt
sich offen
so ist in einem gespräch auch eine
drag-queen zum thema vielfalt zu gast
der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz sprach sich zudem
erneut für die segnung homosexueller
paare aus ich möchte dass wir ihnen den
segen gottes schenken auch über das
thema macht und missbrauch wurde
teilweise heftig diskutiert in der
evangelischen kirche hatte es in letzter
zeit spannungen mit dem betroffenen
beirat gegeben
die gerade neu ins höchste leyen amt der
evangelischen kirche gewählte anna
nicole heinrich die mit ihren 25 jahren
für eine neue generation steht will auch
hier ansetzen
beim thema sexualisierte gewalt das
thema macht mich natürlich auch
betroffen und berührt mich als präses
der ekd synode ist es jetzt auch mit
meiner aufgabe in den nächsten wochen
und monaten zu konkretisieren wie die
einbindung von betroffenen auf der
nächsten synode ausschauen kann
der kirchentag dieses mal fast
ausschließlich digital aber auch in
verschiedenen gemeinden in deutschland
gab es ökumenische projekte hier im
hessischen lich sind die gläubigen
engagiert bei der sache wünschen sich
aber auch veränderungen ein
begegnungsort für die menschen sein ich
wünsche mir dass eine kirche wirklich
viel wertschätzende auch konkret
wertschätzende gegenüber anderen
lebensformen lebensformen wird über
homosexuelle beziehungen oder wieder
heiratete geschehene
am mainufer in frankfurt wird morgen der
große abschiedsgottesdienst des dritten
ökumenischen kirchentags gefeiert eine
der wenigen möglichkeiten für reale
begegnung vor dem sportstudio gleich die
meldung zweier historischer erfolge aus
der fußball bundesliga
robert lewandowski vom deutschen meister
fc bayern hat gerd müllers rekord von 40
treffern in einer saison eingestellt
der weltfußballer erzielte im spiel beim
sc freiburg per elfmeter sein saisontor
nummer 40 und erreichte damit die
bestmarke aus der spielzeit 1971 72 und
den klassenerhalt haben sich der fc
augsburg und hertha bsc gesichert ebenso
wie mainz 05 die rheinhessen nach nur
sieben punkten in der hinrunde hatten
die lottozahlen ohne gewähr
25 15 25 26 41 superzahl 1 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text
das wetter bleibt wechselhaft die sonne
kommt aber immer mal durch
morgen gibt es häufig schauer mitunter
auch gewitter bei längerer bewölkung und
mäßigem wind in gewitternähe kann es
stürmisch werden weil 13 bis 18 grad
auch die kommenden tage bringen
aprilwetter im mai kräftige schauer
meist kurze gewitter dazwischen
sonnenschein und gleichbleibende
temperaturen jetzt wünschen wir ihnen
einen schönen sonntag und wünschen uns
am abend dann ihr interesse für die
sonntagsausgabe des kanals bis dahin
land
[Musik]